los super ricos continúan
enriqueciéndose es una de las
conclusiones del nuevo informe las
desigualdades matan de oxfam
internacional la organización señala que
los 10 hombres más ricos poseen ahora 15
billones de dólares la pandemia ha sido
una mina de billones de dólares los diez
hombres más ricos del mundo han
duplicado sus ingresos en los últimos
dos años la acumulación en la cima
contrasta con el 99 por ciento de la
humanidad cuya situación ha empeorado
como resultado de la pandemia
la ong destaca que los diez hombres más
ricos han aumentado sus fortunas a ritmo
de 15.000 dólares por segundo y de 13
mil millones al día durante la pandemia
al mismo tiempo la desigualdad global
contribuye a causar una muerte cada 4
segundos oxfam apunta que 173 millones
de personas cayeron en la pobreza desde
marzo de 2020 para contrarrestar la
desigualdad creciente la organización
pide a los gobiernos que impongan un
impuesto temporal de hasta un 99 por
ciento a estas fortunas para financiar
el acceso universal a las vacunas y los
servicios sociales
y muchos de los objetivos que teníamos
en términos de reducción de la pobreza y
de la brecha de género ha retrocedido
durante la pandemia por lo que se
necesita una fuerte intervención y
realmente es una elección porque esta
desigualdad extrema es evitable y se
puede combatir os voto a 3 oxfam
internacional también alerta que la
pandemia ha agravado la desigualdad de
género en 2020 las mujeres perdieron
800.000 millones de dólares y hay 13
millones menos de mujeres trabajando que
en el 2019